we flew him all the way from Aurora
Colorado my hometown he's the number
three bantamweight in the world I've
known this kid since he was 15. it's
Corey sanderhagen on this week's food
truck Diaries and I'm feeding them
breakfast burritos let's go
[Music]
it's Corey Santa Hagen what's up what's
going on brother not much how are you
coming off a big win big win making the
rounds media wise become a pretty
popular face these days how do you feel
about it man uh yeah I mean I'm
obviously super happy with how I did I'm
uh you know like martial arts is always
kind of like this uh like self-improving
thing that I got going on and uh I was
I'm really coming on to some really good
[__] I think as far as like becoming a
better fighter and just you know more
present person so I'm pumped about it
man yeah I think looking at your
performance you know I followed your
career since day one man even before the
UFC you'd be in a high ALT 2 guy and I
remember you coming in there as this
lanky basketball player and then I mean
Jesus Christ are you the best in the
world life is crazy man life is crazy
yeah I remember you walking in like it
was yesterday and just like holy [__]
what do you like it and then Christian
even that one's like yeah he's athletic
but let's get his basketball player you
know he's a basketball player white
basketball player dude you know he's
going to be athletic and the next you
know you're one the best the world but
you look at your fight with Cheeto ver
and you're probably exhausted talking
about after doing Rogan for three hours
with in side note here have you ever
talked to somebody in your life for
three hours dude no dude I I remember a
specific moment we were like maybe two
hours in Jamie pulled something up on
the screen yeah and I had to like look
at the time you had to be like I suck
how long is this you're like you know
like oh it's like this warp like weird
like alternate world and like Theo
bonded for the first time he called me
goes damn man because I don't even talk
to my mom that long he's like you know
I'm talking about therapist for three
hours man but with Rogue you just he's
so good at it and there's there's no you
know everything's so tight and he can go
so many places where it's never on the
guest and that's why he's the best to
ever do it because after a while like
when we do fight campaigns he's like
dude we're up four hours I'm like what
four hours dude we could do this for
[__] 48 Hours yeah he's just he's
just has that god-given Talent so back
but that's just side note so you know
doing Rogan you you know your aerial
you're doing all these shows but I think
where you're at in your career like that
version of you against Cheetos the best
we've ever seen and we just had Cheeto
on uh Cowboys fight campaign she was a
good buddy of mine and that's why I
didn't pick the fight you always pick
the fights love you loved you know
refuse to pick the fight I had my
opinions on it but
um didn't put it out there in public for
you know multiple reasons but you know
you guys have when I listen to Cheeto
talk about the fight listen you talk
about the fight and it's exactly what I
think the fans saw is you had kind of
this out of body experience it's the
best I've ever seen you know just
mentally you put everything together
there was really no mistakes the judges
were so off I thought and then with
Cheeto he's like he's one of the worst
nights of my life he's like I just I I
think it's kudos to you being so goddamn
goodies I just couldn't get going I
couldn't get anything going and he goes
and I knew it in the locker room it's
just like just give me a tough night
especially against guy like Corey it's
been a very tough night for me like he
knew it and then you knew it and it was
just this symbiotic thing and it was
like boom he looked fantastic yeah I
mean I felt obviously really fantastic I
I probably felt if if I were to look
back and try to compare to any other
feeling that I've had before going into
a fight it was like super similar to
When I fought Marlin the first time
where like when I was in the back and I
was like no one will beat me tonight you
know like literally no one will beat me
that was the feeling that I had I've
kind of only had that on two occasions
one with Marlon and then one against
Cheeto have you ever thought about like
how can you get there and someone's
asked me this before like I had it
happen once in my entire career once and
I I wish I was more present at the time
or get to being present um I wish I was
more present at the time because when I
fought Gabriel Gonzaga and Anaheim on
the main card I it was like uh I was in
that flow state where it was if you've
seen the old school Spider-Man Toby
Maguire is my Spider-Man by the way
that's how old I am but you know when uh
he's in the he first gets a spider
skills gets bit and that guy's throwing
punches at him in the school and he's
like looking that's how I felt against
Gabriel Gonzaga I was like oh the he
screwed dude there's no he has not
there's nothing he's gonna do that's
gonna beat me but and I wish at the time
I was young and experience I wish I
would have made note of like what what
got me there how did you get to that
mental space so do you and I know you're
a real cerebral guy if you think about
that like how can you get to that space
you know against moral MRIs or how you
get to that space against you know that
Cheeto bear like how can you do that
every time yes and and I think that
that's like a really important uh thing
that you're saying too is because uh I
think that there's reasons for
absolutely everything when you're like
uh in pursuit of performing at a super
optimal level I don't buy the whole like
oh I just you know like couldn't get it
going that night without there being an
actual reasonable
I do think that there has to be
something going on I think that it
extends past like uh what was I doing
physically where was I mentally because
I think Cheeto even was saying like
physically he just couldn't get going
but his mind and uh and he was ready to
go or whatever but but physically he
couldn't get going I think that
physically I've learned how to Peak
super properly like that will almost
never I feel like being an issue for me
because I figured that piece out the
camps are talking about physical
training making sure your body's not
worn down making sure it's not worn down
making sure that I'm doing the weight
cut correctly putting the weight back on
correctly those are like uh the the
physical piece is easy because it's like
I did this I did this that's black and
white that's pretty black and white the
mental side is where we don't have a
scale for those types of things because
it's a lot harder to uh just there is no
like you step on the scale there's a
number okay I'm losing weight there
isn't that with the brain mentally I'm a
nine yeah but but to your point there
has to be something because when you
look at like I always look at the guys
at the tip of the spear like a a Tiger
Woods in his prime which is a golfer
Superman mental game you look at like
Michael Phelps like hold on you're
telling me that he was able to achieve
that flow state every time he jumped in
that water like he never had an off day
there has to be something there if he
can do it tiger can do it if Jordan can
do it there that they're human that
means there's some sort of formula here
that we can figure out there there is I
I think um I I think that like like and
I have it for 9.99 yeah
dude I'm on my way and it's gonna be a
lot more yeah dude let's figure it out
it's yeah hell yeah man I take notes
like on almost everything that's where I
think that I kind of like separate
myself a little bit from maybe the pack
is uh I'm really really organized in the
way that I do almost everything as far
as like fighting goes
um but anyways to touch on the subject
there is no like mental scale for
anything other than like oh how am I
feeling and I don't really think that a
lot of people are capable one of
checking in with themselves and giving
themselves like a really honest answer
for a number of reasons and then two I I
don't really think that uh uh one
they're not capable but two they don't
really know how to do it yeah and
honestly
you learn how to do it by practice and
practice means I'm checking in with
myself at this many weeks away how am I
doing on on every Monday and Saturday I
write down it sounds like a little we're
on food truck Diaries but I almost like
diary in my book you know about like hey
how how am I doing and one that's just
like to get stuff out but two I'll be
super surprised sometime as to what's
like going on inside me when I'm just
stream of Consciousness you know and uh
I learn a lot about how I'm actually
doing in my mind through like practices
like that and I think that that's like a
super important skill for all fighters
to have because there is no scale the
scale is like the feelings that you have
and if you don't have like a a
connection with those things then you're
just like you're just throwing Dart
Settle yeah you're just going through
the motions and hoping for the best
where you don't have to do it I think
there's something to what you said he
said that's on the aerial interview
where you're saying you know Cheeto goes
Nobody out Works me and I've always been
and and that's a common theme in all
professional sports especially in the
UFC going you know nobody out working on
the hardest worker
when I was fighting I would say that
everyone said that back when I was
saying but also in everyone a lot of
people say it now but you gotta assume
dude like in order to get to the UFC
we're all working at the same level like
some people do it a little different but
in order to achieve you know to be a
professional fighter in the UFC the
biggest organization in the world I
assume that is day one [__] man that
you're working hard so when guys go no
one outworks like how do you know yeah
how do you but we're all I assume we're
all working pretty [__] hard because
we're at the UFC it's like in the NFL
you never hear somebody say that Tom
Brady go I I just I never win the game I
just out work yeah Lamar Jackson it's
like yeah well what no you all work
[__] hard dude you're professionals
yeah but so I think what again to your
point and you alluded to this is what
separates you kind of from the pack is
you are such a cerebral you know kind of
it's almost like you have this science
behind it we're a lot of guys and it's
it's nobody's fault it's just the nature
of the game where it's just like I show
up I fight I fight dude it's like no I
get it but there's a professional
approach here that other athletes are
taking yeah definitely I I think that uh
I take responsibility for every single
piece of my Camp you know like uh my
coaches who are Christian Allen
Carrington Banks and Ryan Hall now
um
I don't really like I asked them for
guidance but they're not they're not
like being like hey dude this at this
time this at this time and and I think
that a lot of people have that
relationship with their coach where
they're being told what to do they're
doing they're acting out these things
and then like they kind of just put all
of their trust in that I do put my trust
in these guys that's why I have them
around but I'm the quarterback in this
entire situation so if there's anything
that goes wrong it was my responsibility
for not seeing it early and that that
approach I think is one that I mean you
get with age uh you get with experience
yep uh because you can't do that if
you're inexperienced right like like you
need to be told what to do until you
start like learning the rules and then
once you get into the rules you can
start deciding which path you want to
take inside of the rules but uh that's
just why I am as a fighter right now and
uh I do that really well and um that's
where I think I separate myself is just
being able to think really critically I
don't think a lot of people are like
taught to think really critically and
that has nothing to do like I don't want
to come off like I'm this righteous
smart guy but like
everyone's different but I I also would
argue that I wasn't always really like
that either this is like uh work at it I
had to work at it and I had to learn how
to be like okay okay that's going to fit
in my game that's not going to fit in my
game this is worth x amount of hours
this is worthwhy amount of hours and
those are just things that like I'm not
smart enough to figure out outside of me
just putting a lot of attention and a
lot of thoughtfulness into it that's
because you know yourself best but you
know there you're one of the first guys
to kind of talk about this but even
before you a guy who kind of approached
it very similar to you is George
St-Pierre let's take a little break here
chat with my boy Corey number three
bantuate in the world because this
episode of the food truck Diaries
brought to you by betterhelp because
getting to know yourself can be a
lifelong process especially because
we're always growing always changing all
right what were you telling yourself a
few years ago are you speaking different
to yourself did you get some help listen
to your friends therapy is all about
deepening your self-awareness and
understanding because sometimes we don't
know what we want and why we react the
way we do until we talk through things
with a professional that's where my
friends have better help connect you
with a licensed therapist who can take
you on that journey of self-discovery
from where wherever you are all right if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try today it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire get
matched with a licensed therapist and
switch therapist anytime you want no
additional charge discover your
potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com
today to get temps off your first month
that's better help.com
this episode of food truck Dives with
Corey Santa Hagin is also brought to you
by the one the only the Old Faithful on
it I'm a busy dude and that's by
designing a lot of my plates so I need
all the help I can get that's why I rely
on the number one nootropic on the
planet I'm talking about Alpha Brain now
there's the basic Alpha Brain for the
common folk out there they've sold over
a million bottles Nationwide but what
you know about Alpha Brain Black that's
the highly concentrated double the
dosage ultimate nootropic on the planet
that's what your boy uses here I swear
by Alpha Brain Black for everything
stand up freaking whatever it is
podcasting just being around the family
I want to have my brain a boom and AIDS
and mental processing it's caffeine free
helps get to that flow State on it also
offers a variety of Alpha Brain whether
you're doing Alpha Brain instant they
have the the instant shot the little
eight ounce pack you drop in eight
ounces of water and you're just in that
flow state but they also offer
kettlebells equipment gear steel Club
Macy's sandbags yoga mats and you need
better nutrition say less on it has
protein powders Warrior bars creatine
fish oil krill oil we got it all so get
your thick ass in shape go to onnit.com
you get temps off everything all the
alpha brains including the Black Label
including Alpha Brain instant including
the Alpha Brain shot we got it all temp
set off on it.com shop now let's get
back to the program he was a very
similar guy I went to train Camp within
Montreal and again he wrote everything
down especially after the Matt Sarah
loss he used to drink red wine cut out
red wine but he'd write everything down
it was like very structured like he he's
one of the Pioneers that brought kind of
that
the change in the UFC from just being
like you know tough dudes who punch each
other face to an actual sport so you had
a training camp everything was
calculated he had mapped out his whole
training camp because before there
wasn't really camps you Spar beat each
other up wrestle a little bit and do the
same thing in the fight and he really
brought it to a professional level and I
credit GSP to the fullest with that and
you're kind of an extension of that you
know GSB has you know ties to Denver and
he was at Grudge and Christian Allen
worked with Matan at least they're
bowling so you know GSP he rubbed off on
everybody there now he's rubbing off I
think worldwide but I think you really
embody what GSP was kind of representing
man and but no one's to me what's crazy
is I don't hear anybody else but you
talk like this yeah everyone else just
kind of like you know same thing you
know I work harder than everybody else
you know I'm gonna knock them out that's
like this common theme we keep hearing I
mean yeah it's almost like to the point
where like it's played out now you know
like I almost feel one that's not really
my personality be like Oh I'm Gonna
Knock this guy out I'm gonna do this
this like one that's like so played out
there it's almost like man I don't
really want to like continue to say this
again it'd be like uh you know Tom Brady
or Josh Allen be like yeah I'm gonna
throw touchdowns
yeah dude that's what you're supposed to
do you know that's not even a sound bite
like they don't want ESPN I was like
give me the mic I'm gonna be throwing
touchdowns on Sunday everyone's like all
right dude yeah that's why we're tuning
in man you know it's obvious but I think
you're changing the game and I think the
it's yeah I think the good thing about
you being at the level you're at
switching UFC being ranked the top three
doing this damn thing and having success
I think one of whether you like this or
not I don't want profession on you but
one of your kind of Journeys in life is
to spread this dude spread it be the
next GSP where GSP was that guy that
change the game forever you can do the
same thing I agree I think that uh
spreading it is something that I'm
trying to like do without overdoing it
because you know uh I still got people
to fight but yeah uh
yeah spreading it is something that I'm
kind of coming into my own too it took
me like a few years because I am like a
little bit of more of an introverted guy
or whatever I like to keep to myself a
little bit it took me a little bit to
kind of like figure out how to uh like
spread my knowledge and you know like
actually help people through the whole
thing with uh but also like being myself
too you need to take care of yourself
first and figure it out within before
you start preaching and it takes like a
level of uh just like being okay with
not being like all of the other sheep
you know like not not being promo guy
not being that guy that's not who I am
so it took me a little bit to kind of
figure out how to uh not put pressure on
myself to be that way and just to like
speak like how we're speaking now and
talk about like the more detailed more
like deeper pieces of fighting which to
me are the most interesting aspects of
this whole martial arts stuff not like
me talking a bunch of [__] to someone on
Twitter no no I agree and I think that's
what like being original being your true
self is what gets the fan base to tune
in you know if you just came out here
like I'm Gonna Knock Out mirab I'm Gonna
Knock Out you know whoever Al Jermaine
or Henry sahud up you're like yeah dude
of course that's what he says you know
but nobody believes it I know if nobody
believes it I know it's run down dude
and it's played out and uh you're a
breath of fresh air man well um let me
feed your smart ass some your Gary vs of
the UFC let me feed uh you some uh
breakfast burritos my man cool all right
let's do it hopefully you'll have a
fight soon so yeah no no no no yeah
foreign
[Music]
southwest chicken wrap please beautiful
spicy oregano I'll do a spicy let's do
it uh what do you like better the
breakfast burrito or that crispy
National one uh that's what I'm sure
let's do that might as well Flex a
little bit
now I'm on my way stayed up every single
night and hustled every day
[Music]
let's do it my man
you uh you said go on the lighter end
because you said so since about two
weeks from your fight or two weeks out
yeah two weeks um two weeks post Cheeto
fight you've been going ham on the pit
in the paint on the diet so it's pretty
like standard for me like I said I take
notes and or like I realize things but
dude for like 10 days after a fight I'm
a bottomless pit until my weight gets
back to like kind of like homeostasis
and yeah and then I like can start to
eat a little bit healthier but for the
first 10 days it's like I think it's
good to get out of your system though
because then you're like that's why I
don't eat like this I feel awful I think
your body needs it yeah things about it
needs a lot because you've been
depleting all the nutrients
and you you'll get up to how big before
you're like you know I'm gonna
I don't look like Brendan Fraser from
the whale
I know when I'm a little bit above 160.
and that's about
when I'll start to call it because I
don't really want to like uh I still
want to train well too
so I don't want to get like super big
and then train like a fat ass yeah
what's the point yeah
and I feel like that's how people get
hurt too 100 yeah and then all that
weight that that's your weight on your
body and try to move and then if you're
too heavy you know guys like Petty Puma
talk about like and then then my boy
Mark Muse do this and then your Camp is
basically cutting weight not even
focusing on the fight yeah it's a
disaster yeah disaster and I already
have to be like super pretty much super
strict for the whole entire Camp anyway
so yeah
um so my cuts aren't like the worst
thing in the world like I know I have a
big frame but I'm like built like a
narrow guy yeah so my cuts aren't the
worst thing in the world but I
definitely have to like be on you gotta
be hard yeah otherwise the cat Cut can
be miserable yeah and that's where it
beats you up yeah so for you
like timeline the you know the
bandweight division you're in it's kind
of it's a little complicated at the top
you're right three you got sugar ranked
up above you you got murab ranked above
you and then uh obviously Al Jermaine
and then tohuto are fighting so it's
kind it gets a little clouded up there
right and that you I know after at the
fight you called out murab which I
thought was gutsy as [__] just because
no one's really calling him out like it
it's weird for a guy to call out that
type of fighter especially coming off
that win against Peter John
and when you did it
and this is again this is the manager
side of me like oh I want to call it
Sugar Man that's the fight like
stylistically it's an easier fight for
him you know suga's the bigger name so
the manager at me was like ah dude he
messed up and I know chill Soden said
the same thing so me and chill I think
you think similar when it comes to that
business side of things but then when I
heard you explain like nah man that's
not like he's it would make sense that
people think I'd call him out because
he's the bigger names more popular guy
but the toughest fight and why I got in
the UFC is to find he called the marabs
of the world like that's what I'm going
for when I heard that I'm like yeah that
makes sense yeah I would say that um one
thing that I've been able to do fairly
well in my career is I think a couple
years ahead you know uh I I don't want
to like just attack the like more
popular Shiny Toy or whatever you know
and and have happy to fight me and Sean
will fight one day you know like that
that's definitely probably in the next
year too I agree uh like we will
definitely fight so that fight will
happen when it happens but for me
I want to fight these like really tough
wrestler guys before I get the belt yeah
I don't want to like have the belt and
then not have any confidence in fighting
that type of person like the that and
that's just like long Vision stuff you
know like when you're building up a
fighter uh because I do some coaching
now you like give them certain
challenges at certain times like you
don't just overwhelm them right off the
bat with giving them like a super tough
matchup that's not going to be favorable
for them you give them fights at the
right time so that they can really like
uh like different challenges yeah
different challenge unboxing has done
for years yeah for whatever reason makes
martial arts and thank God you know and
they're trying to move towards that
direction but yeah in boxing like you
know got like 10 and up like all right
we're gonna give you a tough guy you're
not gonna be able to get on the first
three rounds any South Pole so you can
see a South Park you need a little bit
of danger but you should be able to beat
them but in MMA it's a little different
man it is a little bit different but
everyone just wants to be there and it's
another one of those things that's just
so played out to me it's like everyone
is super and me included before uh
everyone is Super Hyper focused on like
how do I get the belt and what's the
easiest route to the belt because like
you make you know maybe a hundred grand
a couple hundred grand more if you're
the title holder yeah maybe maybe more
for some of those guys but for me man
it's like okay so I want to win the belt
what what do I need to do before that
happens so that when I do get the belt I
can hold on to that thing for a really
long time and that's fighting a super
good wrestler like I don't you there's
there's that piece of it there's like me
wanting to challenge myself before I
even get to the Belt but then too like I
was talking to Ryan Hall about this
who's like a really fun guy to talk to
just about life and martial arts in
general super smart and like really
thoughtful has thought of everything
that I've ever thought of really you
know I feel like uh maybe not but I know
where you're going so with morale it's
like the challenge there you know when
it comes to the ground especially with a
guy like Ryan Hall you know it's the
ground game there's gonna be key it's
gonna be a key piece that's a key piece
also I would say the reason that I want
to fight a marab yeah instead of like an
O'Malley too is I I don't want to be the
champ if I'm not the actual best in the
world and I don't really think that a
lot of people really think like that
either you know like maybe I'm giving
myself a little bit too much credit but
I do not want the belt if I am not the
best in the world and and I go into
fights like that too it's like okay
we'll see who's better if I'm not better
than this guy I do not want to win I
don't I don't want like some [__]
way of me winning like it like to hear
Cheetos say that he was like on his
worst day or or like he wasn't having an
off night like uh that like irks me a
little bit inside because I'm like man I
wanted him on his best night you know
like that that's who I wanted and a lot
of people say that but I don't really
think that they mean no and before when
I used to say that I didn't really mean
it and that was like years and years ago
of course but I've gotten really
comfortable with being like you know
what man like if that person deserves to
win more than me because they did more
correct things throughout their life I
can live with that and that's what I
want yeah like that is what I want I
don't and it's the same thing with the
title man like I don't want to be a
world champion if I'm not the actual
best in the world so yeah fighting it
makes sense when you explain it makes
sense the business side of me was like I
know and then but then when you call it
murab I was like oh that's interesting I
[__] hate the business side of stuff
no it's the worst it's the worst I
ignore it as much as I can and you're
doing a good job at it and you're
calling out Mirage went against what I
think everybody was thinking and you
know but that's you that's your path man
and that's what this is why you're an
outlier now you know
let's take a little break from chatting
with Corey Santa Hagin on food truck
Dyers because I got something to tell
you guys if you want the best Kratom on
the planet the only Kratom that I trust
to put in this thick baldy you're
talking about happy hippo they provide
the best Kratom on the planet the safest
the most reliable it's happy hippo.com
use promo code thick23 you save 20 for
the rest of your life share that with
your friends your aunt your stepmom
whoever you want they can all get this
discount and you can create them a
variety of uh forms you can get the
instant shot which I use I use the sour
apple or butterscotch you can do pills
you can do powders gummies however you
want to get your Kratom you do it at
happy hippo it's happyhippo.com promo
code thick 23 thick with three C's 23 20
off you're welcome let's get back to the
program and when you look at again when
you look at the division it's like you
have cejudo algerman which we can get
into after this but
with marab you know you called him out
he was down for it and then we haven't
heard much since you know and then there
was some speculation that he might go a
different direction
have you have you heard that um but even
that hasn't got like so it's like I
don't know what the hell's gonna happen
so that's like another thing too that uh
I think a lot of people don't really
realize also is that behind the scenes
there's like a ton of things already in
motion so like I'm not gonna call out
also I'm not gonna call out Sean
O'Malley because I'm pretty sure there
was like a lot of Whispers that he was
going to be the guy that fights the
wieners sudo and Sterling he came out
and said it for sure I'm guaranteeing
that so you're like all right well it
makes no sense for me to call exactly
exactly and I know that that's like
always destined to change and I
definitely could have like tried to push
the UFC in the direction that I wanted
to go in and not the one that he wanted
to go in and that's a piece of it too
but apparently I was hearing you know
Umar came out and said that him and uh
marab were supposed to fight which
doesn't make too much sense to me I mean
good fight but for Umar it's like was he
um yeah something like something like
that but either way nowhere near the top
five don't make a ton of sense to me
yeah uh me neither really but uh I
understand you know like he's done well
in his UFC career so far but and and I'm
not one of those guys that's like
or not too much of one of those guys I
do think that there should be some type
of uh like rules you know like hey like
fight yeah you fight here but yeah yeah
there has to be that going on of course
uh just to make it fair you know just
because that's like a piece of you know
that's like justice but you know
yeah in 16 the NFL and be like I still
think they should make the playoffs yeah
well no they didn't get there though
dude you know but also for the fan base
we need some sort of structure we can
follow that's even with like you know
Izzy coming off one of the you know the
biggest win of his career against Alex
Pierre
you know everyone's like comes Lots next
and I'm the biggest homslot family hold
on there has to be some sort of order
here you can't go from 170 and not being
a title you know winner there and then
just jump over to 85 which you haven't
competed at at this level and then just
fight the champ like that's they
disrespect to Izzy but B District to all
the other guys that have worked their
asses off man you know you just there
has to I get it what sells tickets we
have to establish some order here a bit
Yeah there there should be it's still a
little bit of entertainment wwe-ish I
get that but it's still a real sport
yeah yeah it's definitely still a real
sport and the entertaining stops right
when the cage closes correct
um and then it's not a show anymore it's
a fight so
um but yeah so I was hearing maybe Rob
and Umar we're gonna fight I'm not sure
when they're fighting
I know figuredo's coming up
yeah I don't know because I'm trying to
think because in my head and in my
fiance's head we kind of have to I if I
want to fight before September 1st which
is when I'm supposed to get married
um it's kind of got to happen in like
July or August you know so yeah so they
would need to figure out okay yeah yeah
so I'm meeting with him in a couple
weeks so I'll kind of like pick their
brains then and see see what's a good op
I mean figured out a huge name that'd be
a great main fight especially while the
rest of division figures out you would
the you know the sahuto and al-jamaine
and then you got Murad they got
um you know sugar doing his thing for
you like that figurito fight would be
huge and then I you know
the Peter yonders make too much sense
for you at all at this point you know
him coming off last and what you're
doing then also
um I think Rob font period makes a lot
more sense even Cheeto uh Peter young
but there's so many directions they can
go
it's just for you until you said that
yeah the figarito probably makes the
most sense if they're gonna do the
barab's not you and morob's not gonna
happen yeah if they're doing that but uh
I'm almost positive the next one that I
fight for will be some type of number
one Contender spot so yeah I almost feel
like it has to be and I think that they
kind of know that too that was actually
a nice thing that I kind of got a little
bit of relief from after the Cheeto
fight is like I feel like I got a lot of
people on board with me you know 100 and
I think I got a lot of people on board
from the UFC on me too great so
um which is key yeah it is key
um which I didn't ever really feel like
I had that before I agree but you know
like San Antonio selling out the entire
Arena putting on a badass performance
against someone who's seen as like this
really you know
but I also think like if you want to
went in there and head kicked them in
three seconds I don't think you get the
same respect that you're getting now
like I think put on the performance you
had for those five rounds and really be
like no no I was the better fighter that
night like that's what the UFC needed to
see but but again all this we talked
about you know matchups and UFC you can
go with figarito or Peter Young or Rob
like if you can't control it you know it
changes like this yeah and like I think
you know you talk about not having that
pressure and taking the pressure off
yourself and again I wish in hindsight I
would have reflected my career a little
more and like don't worry about stuff
you can't control like you're adding all
this pressure and you have nothing to do
with it the FC is going to do whatever
the hell they want to do you you don't
work for the UFC man you're not in the
you know you work from but you're not
making the decisions you can only
control what you can control and once
you realize that's like all good man
yeah you know it's all good because I
mean you know just being a fighter in
the sport man like
one of the more stressful pieces is the
in-between time when you don't really
know who you're fighting when you're
fighting what what type of matchup
they're gonna give you it is and it's
like super stressful and it's like
that's like a thing to deal with in its
own but I also feel like I'm at a very
good point in my skills where I I feel
super comfortable taking any challenge
at this point with where I am yeah so
um at this point it's like okay before
it was like hey let's take this fight at
this time let's take this fight at this
point it's like no like I'm ready to be
champ and I actually feel like I mean
that as far as like where my skills are
where my head is yes where my spirit is
that that's where I am now so at this
point it's like yeah whatever challenge
so I don't really I'm not stressing too
much about like who am I getting next
but I almost am certain it's going to be
for a number one Contender spot it would
have to be something ranked number three
and then also the one of the things that
should give you some sort of peace of
mind is be number three there's only by
three three guys cry fight in the world
it's not like a pool of ten it's just
not the way it works there is some
structure there you know so that helps
yeah and when you look at sahudo and
algerman how do you I'm sure people ask
you to break it down before
interesting fight I think it's an
interesting fight
um I guess if I had to call it one
a lot of people still sleep on Sterling
uh you know like they still sleep on
them which is
you know
kind of crazy to me I think it's because
the the Peter yawn fights right maybe
that and he can become champ like they
hoped he would yeah so people get caught
up on that and then they can't
get off that it's like no he's really
[__] good dude yeah he is good he
also has nothing to do with that stuff
yeah and and I see him as like a I think
he's a pretty hard worker too you know
so uh I I know that he's likely been
improving
I know he's a pretty smart guy too he
he's like uh he's a cerebral fighter I
would consider him in my in in my
opinion of him so that fight with him in
suhudo I could see
tough fight to call right it's super
hard because I mean who knows what the
hell sahudo's been doing but my guess is
suudo
it has been turning hard and you know
the guy was an Olympic champ at 18. so
it's not like he's right like at this
point it's like yeah he's a terrible guy
too yeah and he's not gonna forget how
to ride a bike you know like uh no
matter how many years it's been so I see
that fight as being it's going to be
more of a striking fight and I think
sojudo's gonna try to get some takedowns
just to nullify the closeness and
striking that I think it's going to be
because Sterling is going to be a lot
longer he's going to be a lot bigger and
I think that that's going to make for a
lot of challenges for sahuto
and I don't really know that sujudo's
like path to Victory is going to be
taking him down and holding them down I
think that's by his greatest path to
Victory right this kind of taking him
down home down I think tougher than you
know tougher than he would think even
though tenders to Judo yeah he's a Gold
Medal winner but you know I do think the
the explosiveness of Al Jermaine and
also his finishing ability you know with
you know he does a lot of dangerous
things they can't really plan for you
know and he does have that killer
instinct you know he's really good if
you get your back which I could see
happening but yeah it's just you don't
and that that fight's too cuffed or call
it's all and what version of Henry
sahudo do we get sure you know do you
think if it's like a optimal Henry
sahuda then he'll win
oh like do you think like Henry suhuto
like him
at his like Peak like when he was
beating Cruz in Marlin do you think that
that guy beats Sterling that guy's
pretty [__] guy yeah he is pretty
good yeah like it's pretty good it's
also the game even you know think about
it he retired how long ago not just a
few years ago and then he's coming back
the games even involved since then
that's how new the sport is I know it
evolved so fast isn't it cool if you
look at like the top 10 two years ago
it's like yeah not the same almost not
even close dude yeah that's cool it's
dope yep uh but dude you know I I love
the hell out of you you're getting
married in September hopefully you get a
fight before then so it doesn't mess up
the wedding honestly I'm gonna do it
either way
you know like I'm gonna do it either way
you know but you can tell them that like
dude like we play this has happened in
September I told Erica that I'm gonna do
it either way and she's like okay but
just like please God promise me that
you'll do your best stick too and I was
like I'll do my best but yeah she's like
cool we have a fight for you October 1st
but this is uh not a wedding gift man
just a gift you come on the show nice
sneak your guys for my boys and suplex
in Philly hell yeah I know you like to
go out there in nature
Carhartt nice oh cool yeah those are
dope man those are hard to find oh yeah
so we can do some work in those man man
I love them thank you of course yeah
dude I got zero Styles so I mean like
thank you the more success you have like
even when you got in the car I'm like
Dennis dude's getting pretty fancy yes
it's your style what's your style man
yeah yeah which works brother yeah but
keep doing you man I think you're just
uh you're exactly where you're supposed
to be man you're exactly where you're
supposed to be and uh I just you can
tell like the experience everything's
just it's coming together brother yeah
it's it's insane to me to think you walk
in high altitude and then you'll be
world champion dude yeah crazy yeah it's
great yeah that's exactly what you
should be doing brother thank you so
thank you for doing the show man
hopefully that um we got southwest
chicken wrap but hopefully I didn't put
that yeah I don't add to that you know
but good luck with the wedding man wish
you the best we'll see you soon thank
you everybody